guys welcome back today we're gonna use
an ideal 48 inch tiller you can see
right here in a previous video we use an
all-purpose plow
three passes down and back this is the
finished results we're going to compare
those results versus the results of a
tiller this is the same day alright so
we went and hooked this up right
afterwards gonna go down and back see
the results with one pass compared to
three passes if needed we'll go down and
back again and i think i'm gonna run
this tiller over top of what i plowed
already that's just not a good enough
result for me there to want to plant in
so i'm going to finish that out smooth
it out for a good seed bed before we
seed later this spring now you guys know
i'm a big fan of dirt dog equipment but
dirt dog does not offer a four foot
tiller so something for your subcompact
tractors the 1025r kubota bx anything
and that smallest footprint of modern
day tractors so the 48 inch that we
offered this year is by ideal farm
equipment so this is going to be similar
to the dirt dog that is a made in the
usa with some foreign or imported
components like the gearbox for example
so we're trying to get away from the
maiden china stuff whenever possible
last year you saw us running tar river
tillers and land planes and it was
kind of our last season with them for a
number of reasons but so we're switching
over to more north american-made
companies as is the gist of it so this
ideal tiller is gonna be four foot wide
it's gonna have a slip clutch on it
something that i actually notice i don't
see very often is um just basically slip
clutch maintenance or almost like a
checklist over here on the sticker so
that's kind of nice to see too so we'll
have similar features what you expect
what you want to see on a tiller so i've
got the gearbox up here this is gear
driven on the side it's not going to be
chain driven i like that a little bit
more robust i believe
swing gate on the back with this chain
so you can adjust that swing your gate
open if you want to or not you're going
to have a parking stand over on this far
side now this has four blades per flange
and the thought process i think with
ideal is that you're going to put less
strain on a subcompact tractor versus a
six blades per flange so we'll be able
to see if there's a difference in
performance as we're tilling today but
something interesting is that on the the
flanges themselves that the blades bolt
onto there's extra holes on there
there's four extra holes you have two
bolts per flange so potentially you
could stagger in a different way add
another flange or two more
wow look at them geese
that's a flock
so what i was saying was that on the
flanges underneath here right now you
have four blades per flange but there's
extra holes in those flanges so there's
four extra holes total which would
equate to a total of two extra blades so
i almost feel like you could potentially
add more blades onto each flange if you
wanted to but we'll check out the
performance with four blades see how it
does and we can make a determination
from there a couple more features you
might be interested in this whole plate
that you see down here kind of
underneath the housing is adjustable up
and down so you have multiple bolt holes
so you can adjust this kind of skid
runner to help out with your depth and
speaking of max depth it is up to a
seven inch tilling depth which is
typically unheard of on a four foot
tiller i don't really see the need to go
seven inches down but it's nice to know
you can and of course if you didn't
notice this is quick hitch compatible
we're using the spiko cat one quick
hitch this one does not use any bushings
all right so we sell an absolute
boatload of these things for that very
reason but you don't have to use a quick
hitch if you want to just hook it right
up to your category one three-point
hitch you can do that as well it's
standard 540 rpm rear pto just got the
pto shaft hook it up right to the back
of your tractor have the safety chains
the shaft cover all that good stuff too
now something that's mentioned on this
sticker on this side and maybe somewhere
else as well and just for your general
information most gearboxes these days
are coming empty without any oil in
there maybe there's just a trace film
just to kind of coat the inside of the
gearbox but that's due to different
shipping regulations federal regulations
that
limit or or don't allow at all any
fluids to be shipped and so that's the
reason behind that so it's always a good
idea to check your gear boxes before you
get to work and speaking of work we're
going to get to it right now as always
we're sponsored by borah wheel spacers
they are made in america have a lifetime
warranty if your tractor feels tippy
side to side especially if you have a
cab on it then adding a set of wheel
spacers can make a big difference get
more information on them at the link
down below
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so we just did one pass down a
one pass back so that's single
coverage right there and it is slower
than using the plow there's no doubt but
when you have to go multiple passes to
get these results
versus one pass to get those results
i'll leave that up to you now you're
going probably twice as deep
with the
the all-purpose plow compared to the
tiller that's about four inches deeper
so maybe four and a half some are right
in there i would guess this is around
eight
maybe nine in certain places but it's
inconsistent right there's a lot of
areas that didn't get plowed up so you
have those
deeper furrows that did get plowed up
and then chunks of sod that are still in
place and that's after three passes back
and forth and it was a very jarring ride
doing that this was a very smooth ride
very easy to do a consistent seabed all
the way across there and you can still
see some
grass and other debris and matter that's
on top here but
same thing in the all-purpose plow area
as well so what i think is that you're
getting better results in my opinion
with the tiller a more consistent seed
bed so that when you go to seed you're
going to have an easier
chance or more
higher likelihood i guess of having
consistent seed depth so if your clover
seed needs to be a half inch down or
brassicas need to be an inch or inch and
a half or two inches whatever it is
whatever you're planting
you're going to have a more consistent
chance to do so versus having chunks of
sod that are way up high and
very solid other areas that haven't been
tilled and turned at all and then deep
referrals that are just going to be
tough to work with and you really
wouldn't want to plant in this you'd
want to come back through with something
else a disc maybe break up those clods a
cultipacker to smooth it out as well but
again
it's a lot more work a lot more passes
to get the same result as what a tiller
can do in just one or two passes so at
this point i'm going to leave what i
just tilled all alone i'm going to come
through what i plowed with the
all-purpose plow and try to get that
resembling somewhat uh what the tiller
did over here and then well let's see
we're in april probably about a month
and a half still technically i'm
probably a little early on my tilling
we're going to come back through and
plant our screening cover that we have
so it's a giant screen it'll grow up to
it's over 12 foot tall in one season so
you can plant it even in in june and
still get i think it's over 10 foot in
height it's a crazy cool
type of plant that you can get and so
we're actually a new dealer with
northwoods whitetails
who sells this product along with all
sorts of food plot seeds too so we're
going to plant plots all over this place
this year get the screening cover here
closer to the road a lot of different
areas so access to stands that kind of
thing too going to have a lot of fun so
if you want to see what's going on out
here at the property see more tractor
videos in general we'd love to have you
tag along hit that subscribe button and
so let's get this section tilled up here
and see if we can get ready to seed
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
all right guys i'm going to finish up in
just a minute but these next two rows
here were done over the plowing that
we'd already done with the all-purpose
plow so
i mean these results are just so much
better i don't
i don't really see the need the
requirement to plow before you till
i mean what we did over here just
tilling
plowing and then tilling and then just
plowing you can see the results i think
speak for themselves okay we're just
wrapping up just thought of it but
this is the performance with four blades
per flange on the tiller all right so
i've always used six blades per flange
there's no way you could tell the
difference between four and six blade
this did just as good as any
six blade
tiller that i've used so
i think you might be able to add more
blades onto this one if you needed to i
don't know for sure i'll have to verify
that but the way it set up stock with
four blades on each flange works pretty
darn good so i'm gonna get that knocked
out but if you guys are in the market
for something for your tractor whether
it's for the three-point hitch or the
front end loader could be pallet forks
could be a snow pusher
it could be a tiller could be a snow
blower it could be a brush hog you name
it we can help check out
goodworkstractors.com we do sell and
ship all over the country if you enjoy
watching tractor videos we'd love to
have you tag along hit that subscribe
button right underneath the video i want
to thank you for taking time out of your
day to stop by and until next time stay
safe we'll see you soon
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]